(applaudissements)
- Pour la première fois
en deux ans, des centaines
de finissantes en sciences
infirmières de l'Université
de Montréal ont eu droit
à une collation des grades
en personne.
Cette année, au Québec,
elles sont 2758, tout niveau
d'études confondu, à rejoindre
le réseau de la santé.
- Oui donc, beaucoup de cadeaux?
- Oui, de mes parents qui m'ont
appuyée tout le long de mon
parcours au baccalauréat,
puis ça s'est bien passé.
J'ai vraiment aimé.
- L'intérêt pour la profession
aurait bondi. L'université
observe une hausse de 10 %
de ses demandes d'admission.
MARJOLAINE HÉON, vice-doyenne
Faculté sc. infirmières, UdeM
- Il y a vraiment une fibre
altruiste. Je pense que la
pandémie est peut-être venue
réveiller chez certains de nos
étudiants, le côté de dire :
"Voici, moi aussi, je veux
contribuer."
- Mais actuellement, le manque
d'infirmières demeure, rappelle
le ministre de la Santé.
CHRISTIAN DUBÉ, ministre Santé
du Québec
- Sur u'on cherchait,
il y en a 2500 qui sont déjà là.
Mais ça en prend plus.
Alors, il y a aussi des choses
qu'on va améliorer.
- C'est sûr que c'est quelque
qui vient aussi avec
la profession. Donc, on s'attend
des fois à des surcharges de
travail et tout ça. Moi, je suis
allée un peu ouvert, avec dans
le fond ça en tête à laprofessis
tant découragée, non.
- Est-ce que vous vous voyez
faire ça toute votre vie?
- Oui!
- Euh, bien oui! Bien je pense
qu'on est beaucoup aussi dans
l'espoir que les conditions
s'améliorent. Puis, je pense que
pour ça, ça en p
relève, justement. Ça prend
d'autres gens. Oui, on est
passionnées, puis on aime ça,
mais je pense qu'on a aussi
besoin.
de voir des améliorations.
- L'ordre des infirmières
du Quéne diminution de
7 % du nombre d'infirmières
qui décrochent un diplôme
entre 2019 et 2021.
LUC MATHIEU, prés. Ordre
infirmières et infirmiers du Qc.
- On va suivre ça, mais on n'est
pas inquiet. Ça demeure encoret,
c'est une super profession.
Mais encore faut-il lui donner
des conditions d'exercice,
des conditions de travail
qui font du sens.
- Pour Patricia Conrath,
qui pratique depuis une
quarantaine d'années en CHSLD,
l'accompagnement des nouvelles
infirmières est crucial pour
les retenir dans le réseau
de la santé.
PATRICIA CONRATH, VP
infirmière, FIQ | Své
- Je pense que les jeunes
graduées ont besoin de sentir,
pour celles qui sont déjà
dans le réseau, un appui, une
entraide, un esppe,
un certain mentorat.
(cris et applaudissements)
- Ici, Gabrielle Proulx,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.